Evet
evet karşımda
İlerleyen bir Zamanla daha önce hiç
konuşmadım Ben de bu
var ama sayıların ruhsuz olduğunu hep
bilirim ve hiç hoşlanmam Benim Dünyam
kelimeler ve harfler Ama bu ruhsuz olan
sayılar bize çok şey ifade ederler
mesela Derler ki kadınlar
bu erkeklerden
çok uzun gösterdiğim hocam Öyle derler
Ben bunu hep kadınların çok konuşmasına
bağlarım Biz Kadınlar hep birbirimizle
Herkesle her şeyi konuşuruz doğru mudur
Efe Evet konuşuruz Bu bizim daha uzun
yaşamamızı sağlar diye hep düşünürüm bu
arada benim slaytların geçişini sağlamak
için bir aparat rica edebilir miyim
ya ben de gittim efendim çok konuşmayı
sevdiğim için sordum x kuşağı da yani x
kuşağı sizlere doğuran Efendim anneler
Yani benim arkadaşlarıma dedim ki bu
hafta sonu Z kuşağı ile
birlikte olacağım onlarla ilgili bana
iletmek İstediğiniz bir şeyler var mı
söylemek istediğiniz bir şeyler var mı
ne konuşalım gençlerle diye biz bunu çok
severiz her şeyi paylaşırız Çünkü Hatta
bugün
salona girdim dedim ki 8 konuşmacının
arasında tek kadın benim
herhalde süre kısıtlı olduğundan dolayı
bir akademisyen ve bir kadın olan Burcu
Hoca'yı çağırmakta tereddüt ettiler O
yüzden erkek egemenliği burada devam
etmişti düşünmeden de geçemedim Efendim
konuştuk kendileriyle dedi ki acaba ne
anlatalım Ne söyleyelim diye
kime sorsak Z kuşağında iyi geceler
Sen alışkınsın değil mi siz bu
şikayetlere işte En yalnız en mutsuz
işlev hemen Akören sabırsız böyle
artarak giden şekilde şikayetleri var
sizlerle ilgili bu kuşakla ilgili
bu ekmekarası bu limon yerler dedi
Birkaç Z kuşağını anlatan iki kuşağı
arkadaşım Çok ilginç geldi ve Bütün
bunların temelinde bizim zamanında ye ye
büyüdüğümüz güdümlü anne terliği
yemediğiniz için böyle olduğunu
düşünüyorlar kendileri
ya Neyse biz böyle Afili bir başlık
belirledik dedi ki dijital dünyanın yeni
liderleri
bu çünkü biz çok severiz güzel
başlıkları sınırları çizilmiş havalı
şeyleri bizim yaş grubum uzun sosyal
medyadaki bir Yollarına baktığınızda da
ne görürsünüz tonla sıfat görürsünüz
değil mi hiçbir şey yazamayan evinin
hanımı işte Nesrin'in anası şunun eşi
diye yazar biz çok severiz biz de
dünyanın yeni liderleri
ve ben vazgeçtim
bu anlatmayacağım
Yok böyle bir şey anlatmayacağım size
Çünkü ben buraya gelmeden sanırım dört
yılda beş gün önce böyle bir haber
gördüm Bu gördüğüm ilk haber değil bu
konuda bu gördüğüm son haber bu konuda
16 yaşında bir Z kuşağı diye
tanımladığımız o şikayet edip
beğenmediğimiz işte çocuklarımızdan biri
beş gün önce bir etüt merkezinde
maalesef yaşamına son verdi
ya ben de dedim ki canı cehenneme
dijital dünyanın ve onun potansiyel
liderlerinin olması gereken özelliklerin
bu ve oturup antidepresan kullanan
oranlarına baktım Tıp Doktoru değil mi
Evet De hadi açmak istemem O yüzden sayı
vermekten özellikle kaçınıyorum
bu inanılmaz boyutta genç nesilde Z
kuşağında antidepresan bağımlılığı ve
maalesef özellikle Sınav kaygısı
nedeniyle değersiz hissetmek nedeniyle
Az önce gösterdiğim eyleme girişme olayı
Hepsini geç mutsuzlukla ilgili bitiş
bağlantıların olduğu makale okudum
ve hatta bu sırada
sınavlara hazırlanan gençlere spor
müsabakalarında yasaklanan Doping serin
aileler tarafından sınavda yüksek başarı
göstermeleri için özellikle tanıdık bir
şekilde bir Hekim bulunursa yazıldığını
yine okudum birkaç makaleden Doping bu
boyutta mı önemli
en yeni nesil Ergen yeni nesil gençliği
bir tanım çıkarmışlar
ya dedim ya biz çok severiz tanımlamayı
biz size Hatta Bizde öyle 20 yaşına
kadar bakın bomboş beyinle geliyoruz biz
dünyaya ödemi bomboş ama 20 yaşına kadar
herkes bize kendi gerçeğini kabul
ettirmeye çalışıyor doğrusunu ya da
yanlışını Beynimiz bu şekilde doluyor
bunlarla yirmi yaşından sonra biz
bunları doğru olduğunu kabul ederek bir
20 yıl daha yaşıyoruz geliyoruz 40
yaşında da kırk yaşından sonra Eğer
şanslıysan akwe uyandıysan Bak kendi
doğrularımızı yaşam amacımızı Kırkından
Sonra bulmaya başlıyoruz 40'a kadar
böyle geçen bir ömür Eğer farkında
değilsek tüm bunların
o kendi ofisleri gibi
sınırları çizilmiş
Bu bir alanda görünmez Parmaklıkların
içinde yaşayan çoğu e bebeğiniz Ben de
dahil Elbette Ben de okuyacağım bir
insanıyım sizi bu kuşak da suçlamaların
nedeni o sınırları çizilmiş parmaklık
taki koşulları uyumak istemeniz den
dolayı olduğunu düşünüyorum
bu ve bu sınırların içinde yaratıcılık
özgürlük yaratıcı düşünme farklılık
olabilir mi Bence değil
mi Evet aynen böyle diyorlar Biz o
kadarını bilmeyiz Ne yapalım Sistem
bulucam Evet sistem bu hep söylerim
evlerimize misafir gelmiyor paylaşım 0ta
isim yok Var mı hayır yok komşuluk
ilişkisinin den tutunda sokaklarımızda
Çoluk çocuk oynamıyor oynayamıyor Sabah
işe gider gibi bırakılan okula çocuk
akşamın köründe okuldan alınıp
Etüt Merkezi'ne ya da dershaneye
gönderiyor Çünkü oynamasını vakit yok
Hafta sonu da yan komşunun çocuğunun
gittiği etkinlikten benim çocuğum eksik
mi kalsın kurstan diye hafta sonunda
okur senin bu kurs benim şeklinde
dolaştırıyor yine gençlerimiz ve
çocuklarımız
bu ve sonra Biz diyoruz ki e Hem yeni
nesil bunlar hepsi öyleler hep böyleler
bakın anda yaşamak için canları çıkıyor
sizin ebeveynlerini ne demek bu hani
böyle yeni popüler oldu ya Bununla
ilgili kitaplar yazıyor onu da kalmak
falan diye anda kalmanızı
kıskandıklarını düşünüyorum sizin anda
kalabilme yetimizi elinizden almak için
bence kendi kaygı ve korkuları
omuzlarınıza yüklüyorlar
bu Eğer kendi tanımladıkları ki bu
genellikle Merkezi sınavlar oluyor
sınavlardan başarısız olursanız de aç
kalacağınız sevilmeyeceğini Z
da başarısız olacağınız gibi korkularla
sizi andan kopardıkları düşünüyorum yani
sizin yaşadığınız Bu temel problemin
neden index kuşağının bakış açısının ve
Zorlu da yatmasının olduğunu kendi
hayallerini size empoze ettikleri
düşünün kendi beceremedik leri
hayallerini size yaptırmaya
çalıştıklarını hep düşünürüm kendi
yapamadıkları nasıl yapsınlar kredi
borcu ile bağlamışlar zaten halatlarla
kendilerine küçücük bir dar alana ne
yapabilirler o daracık alanda
bu ve
en son olarak Ama neyden önce son olarak
Ama bu ülkede kimsenin açlıktan öldüğünü
düşünmem ve inanmıyorum ama hayallerine
önem verilmediği için değer verilmediği
için
bu
mutsuzluktan yönünü bulamadığı için
amaçsızlık Tan yine başarısız olup
değeri değersiz hissetmekten
sevilmemekten konu komşunun çocuğuyla
kıyaslamaktan
wenice kalabalıklar içinde yalnız
kalmaktan gençlerimiz omuzlarına
yüklenen nice dertten dolayı O
gördüğünüz haberdeki
bu eylemi gerçekleştirebiliyor
mi Evet bunu niye yapıyorlar diye
düşündüm de hepsini düşünürüm Muş gibi
yaşıyoruz bizsiz değil biz x kuşağı gibi
mutluymuş gibi Harikaymış gibi iyi bir
eski bir iyi bir anne gibi bir her şeyde
bir en iyi olma şeyimiz var gibi bizde
var o sizde yok bakın Siz oluşunuz
yazıyorsunuz biz oradan alıp sizi buraya
çekiyoruz Hayır hayır bu iş gibi yapalım
ama ben hep söylerim yemeksepetinde
isimde verdik ama Mahallenin Muhtarı
olmuştum bugün çok a biliyorsun sipariş
verenler bu sıfatla ödüllendiriliyor lar
Ben de bunun ödüllendirilmiş teemix
kuşağı arkadaşlarım kadın arkadaşlarımı
tarafından o kadar yıldırgan almıştım ya
Nasıl yani iyi bir anne sadece evimi
yedirmeli çocuğuna hep bu kalıplarımız
var bizim var sizin yok Size vermeye
çalışıyoruz bunu veya bir gün
çocuklarımın Okulu'nda işte bilirsiniz
böyle anneler eden bir şey yapar getirir
falan ya Herkes çalışıyor dışarıdan alıp
götüreceğiz Belli ki yani niye katıyoruz
alalım sene götüreyim yok o zaman iyi
bir akademisyen sana iyi anne değilsin
yaftası gelecek ya Ne yaptım ben de
gittim pastayı aldım ki koydum Bor cama
vurdum tepesinden Evde yapılmış Üstün
verdim Ben bunu yaptım hangi dışarıdan
aldım götürdüm daha iyi aynı olarak
evdeki yaptıracağım İbra Kale misin Ama
İbrahim aynı zamanda Niye o kalıbı ok mı
durmam lazım taşlamış gibi yaşam
bu öyle bir adanmışlıkla yaşıyoruz yani
size bunu Niye yapıyoruz onu atıyorum
kadın ya eşine alıyor kendini ya
çocuğuna böyle deli gibi oluyor mu yani
bütün hayatı oluyor
bu hobi dersen sadece tüketimle ilgili
hobimiz var İki suçundan bahsediyor
Ondan sonra adanmışlık ne getirebiliyor
musunuz Adam almıştık beklenti getirir
sonra nankör diye işte olayın başında
dedim ya Oturduk konuştuk kadın kadına
nankör bunlar dediler işte beklenti
böyle dur Yani öyle bir alıyoruz ki
kendimizi beklentimiz buralara çıkıyor
bu şikayetimiz de keza öyle
en son olarak şunu söyleyeceğim size
sonra birkaç resim göstereceğim
ben size diyolar ama bence kendileri
Yani bizim kuşak Sen ver bakar mısınız
Şuradaki görüntüye
ülkemizdeki en çok satanlar listesinin
başındaki kitapları isimlerini Şuradaki
altı çizili kelimelere bile bakın
tembelliğimizin yüzümüzü nasıl da
vuruyor sihirli kusursuz mucizevi şifre
tembellik akmıyor mu sanki
O çok mutluyduk da niye on sihirli
formülü ihtiyacımız var Çok başarılıydı
ikta niye kusursuz ya kusurlu değil
kusursuz 20 adımı ihtiyaç duyuyoruz niye
zengin olmak için beş mucizevi adımız ve
zirvenin muhteşem şifrelerine
ihtiyacımız var arkadaşlar Pamuk Prenses
sormuşlar bir öpücükler nasıl uyandım
Pamuk Prenses diye demiş ki uyanmasam
daha çok öpücükler di
O yüzden
uyarsanız iyi olur Daha çok Üzülmemek
için yani farkına varsanız iyi olur
şimdi geldik şuraya en sevdiğim bölüme
kendimi anlatmak değil Elbet derdik
derdim
Hani Efendim beni sunan
beyefendi İşte sağ olsun dedi işte
Türkiye'nin en genç kadın
profesörlerinden biri de daha yürüyen
genç kadın profesörü yanlış dedi
bu x kuşağının ben
bu köy okulunda okudum ben ilkokul
Ortaokulu liseyi açık liseden bitirdim
en iyi dinle Z kuşağı
Sen beni sizin kuşağı alınmaya
anlatıyorum ben oraya ait değilim bu
Sevmem de
Daha sonra ben Efendi'nin dediği sıfatı
almak
Ne gibi bir şeyi başardım başarı
bilmiyorum tanımlardan nefret ederim
başarım sevmiyorum sadece aldım Evet
aldım koydum üzerine bu kadar Çünkü
seviyorum kardeşim çok aşık olmuştum ne
binaya
o binanın önünde böyle gece gündüz
bankoya aşk nasıl bir seviyoruz
bildiğiniz biliyorum da bu farklı bir
aşk starm
sevdiğiniz bir şey yapmak tutkuya Ben
demiyorum ki Emek vermeyin işte kadınlar
toplantımızda diyorlar ki Burcu Hocam
siz eğitimci siniz ama çocukların işte
böyle olmaz kızım çalışsınlar işte ya
ben demiyorum ki onlara çalışmasın lar
Ben diyorum ki standart test test
robotunu çevirmeyin çocuklarımızı ya
atasözü verdiğinde beş tane sıkı aşağıya
yazıp atasözünün doğru sıralanışı
hangisidir dediğimizde hepsi seçuk Hadi
bakalım atasözünün üzerine konuşalım
günlük hayattan denize hepsi susuyor ben
bundan bahsediyorum niye robota
çeviriyoruz biz bu çocukları standart
eslerle standart sınavlarla Benim derdim
o çalışmasın lar demiyorum ki bir de
diyorum ki kendi yaşam amaçlarını
bulsunlar da o zaman siz görün İşte şu
Kadının çalıştığı gibi yani kendi hayali
bu ismin ya biri besyo'ya gidecek Spor
Akademisi Sporcular hep bir konsere ise
kardeşim biri tiyatrocu olacak ya Herkes
mi Doktor olacak herkesin avukatı uzak
ya ya o senin karşı komşu hava atma
aracın değil ki o çocuğu o yüzden mi
doğurdun ya bir karışma
şurada hani gönül dedi kim dedi
bilmiyorum ilk konuşmacılardan burada
oyun Murathan Bey Gönül ya Gönül sadece
Türkçede olan bir kelime biliyor musunuz
Gönül var ya şu gönülde yatan bir şey
var mutlaka herkesin Ya bırak onu
Yaşasın oluşumu yaşasın yani sorun o
neyse işte köy okulu Açık Lise
bildiğiniz falan derken aşık olunan bir
şey böyle kampüste Sürünüyorum yani
öğrendiğim ama şeyden söylüyorum Hani
Yunus Yunus Emre'nin çok severim gözüm
dolar bahsettiğim de hani böyle
heybesini almış gibi o binanın etrafında
falan yani burada öğütmesi olabilir
miyim diye böyle bir aşk geldi benimki
gibi tabi parçada Peri tozu bu derken
oldu işte bir şekilde Neyse sonra
Bu bir şey severek yaptığınızda karnınız
rahat bırakmıyor sizi böyle bir ters düz
garip akıyor
Happy standart olmayan bir şey yapmak
istiyorsunuz Yani benim sıfatına sahip
herkes Efendim görevi neticesinde amfiye
girer işte 250-300 tane öğrenci
antibe dersini anlatır ya da asistanına
verir o anlatır sonra odasına gider
çalışma yapar Bu Böyledir ama ben o
çocuklara böyle kanım deli gibi aktığı
için
bir görev olarak tanımlanmış şeyden daha
fazlasını sadece yapmak istedim ben
Lanet olası Muhasebe dersinde
anlatıyorum çok sıkıcı
bu çünkü çok gerçekten çok sıkıcı ruhsuz
Sayıner var kanunlar yönetmelikler
ben de derse genellikle farklı
kıyafetlerle gitmeyi tercih ediyorum
işte buradaki sunumda çok sıklıkla
kullandığım bir sunum kıyafetim bazen
dersin arasında değiştirip çocukların
dikkatini çekmek için
yaptığım eylemlerden biri yine Mesela
bir EFM paletsiz bu ayaklarım 41 numara
benim Palette 43'e çıkıyor arha kendine
dikkat çekiyor hoş oluyor arkada
ayakkabım var görüyorsunuz yani
sürünüyor yine masanın başında tünel ip
onlara sadece muhasebe değil Yunus
Emre'den de böyle beyitleri okuduğum
anlardan bir tanesi de
odası çeşitli şekillerde Üniversiteye
giriş yapıp çıktığım Doğrudur
diplomasını kafasından böyle teperek
verdiğim anlarda yine öğrencimi çekilmiş
ve gidişlerinde
Ben bilmem bu annelik duygusundan mıdır
nedir
gözlerimin dolu dolu olduğu ve benim bu
Çocuklara bakın ben 1. Sınıfta 18
yaşında çocuklarımız da karşılaşıyorum
doktora sonuna kadar onlarla birlikteyim
Eğer devam ederlerse
o ve ben bir sınıfta test robotuna böyle
dönmüş neredeyse şekilde Toplumsal
olaylara değerlerimizi artık hiçbir
şeyden tadı almaya nice çocukla
çalışıyorum
bu ve beni kalabalıkların içinde onların
kaybolmasını İstemiyorum En azından
benim çocuklarımın İşte o anda amfideki
150 çocuğumun ve Ben onlara diyorum ki
kardeşim Çıkalım dışarıya sokağa çıkalım
bu sokakta ne görürsek ağaç mı dikeceğiz
ağaç dikelim kepçe mi alacağız sürsün
birimiz sürelim köy okullarına yardım
edelim ne dersiniz Hadi gidelim bir köye
nereye Urfa'ya gidelim mi Haydi gidelim
bu Samet'i muhasebe dersi alan
çocuklardan bahsediyorum bakın yani
Benim normalde gidip o muhasebeyi artık
çıkmam gerekiyor değilmi ama ben Harika
bir şey mi yapıyorum Hayır ya sadece
Herkes kendi sorumluluk alanında ilk
nane tozu 2 su şundan bahsediyorum ben
de oradayım Herkes kendi sorumluluk
alanında bu çocukları biraz ilgili Umut
Hayal kurmak bunları aşılırsa başta
gösterdiğim haberler ve antidepresan
oranları olur mu
var bunun için gösteriyorum bunları
harika bir iş yapmış Burcu hoca demeniz
için değil
abone ol
bu köy okullarına sadece benim dersimi
alan öğrencilerle
bu paramız yok bizim yanlış anlamayın
parası mı var bunların Hayır nasıl
olabilir Ben bir devlet memuruyum Onlar
da benim canım öğrenci
var ama biz yollara düşünceyi
bu firmaları ikna edince kaç tane köy
okulunda bilgisayar laboratuarı
yaptırdık biliyor musunuz ve bu gönüllü
bir şey yani ben o çocukları sadece
muhasebeden final yapıp Getiriyorum o
kadar köy Okuluna gidip Urfa'da
bilgisayar laboratuarı yaptırmaları
onları sorumlu değil ama siz Onlara
biraz hayatı anlatırsanız Hadi sokağa
çıkalım derseniz burada bir şeyler
yanıyor Onlarda ve bu onları hayata
bağlıyor
var yani Merkezi sınavların çözeceği
testleri değil bu duygu
bu ve bu laboratuvarlardan nice Tubitak
projeleri çıktığını duyuyoruz Köy
okullarından İlköğretimde özellikli çok
duygulandıran anlardan biridir yine
birkaç size fotoğraf sormak istedim
öğrencilerimizle beraber
tanseli çocuklarımıza ve huzurevlerine
böyle gönüllü partiler yaptığımızı yine
şehrimizde bulunan zihinsel engelli
çocuklarımıza bizim öğrencilerimizle
birlikte yaptırdım bir etkinlikten
kareler onları bir günlük ya bir günlük
bedelli askerlik var değil mi o
çocuklarımız için niye bir günlük
üniversite yok diye düşünüp gidip onları
almıştık aileleriyle beraber ve Daha
sonrasında onlara
aileleriyle birlikte misafir edip
bir günlük üniversiteli yapmıştık çok
sevdiğim bir fotoğraf her sunumda
kullanırım yine öğrenci evi
ziyaretlerinden biri çoğunlukla böyle
akşam yemek Bu kapı Giderim Bu fotoğrafı
özellikle çok seviyorum
Bu bir baka baka çakal da biri
Bu yan tarafı kepenk O gördüğünüz
boşaltmış böyle kiraya veriyor artık
kirayı siz düşünün ne kadar dedim Yavrum
bu ne ilk eve gittiğimde de evin
orasında kepenk var böyle Hocam dedi
Bakkal amca bizim Kayseride de işte
bölmüş bakkalı yarısını da kiraya verdi
dört kişi kalıyoruz burada böyle
kepengin altında Elif geçiyorsun ya
Herkese
helva kalmıştım bende Erzurumluyum ben
bu arada iyi helva kırarım ünlüdür Bizim
oralarda çocuklarda canları çekmiş
onlara götürdüm Bir geceden yine kalma
fotoğraflar şu gülüşe şu gülüşe ömür
verirse o
Evet efendim Beyefendinin
beni tanımlarken bir sınav sorusundan
bahsetmişti hızlıca geçeceğim sürem
oldukça azalmış hemen toparlıyorum
dediği sınav sorusu Evet finali gittim
Afiye oturdum arkadaşım finali kendime
yapıyorum oturun orasını ver yapacağım
dedim sorular bana dedim ama bu muhasebe
sorusu değil de elbette de duygusal
finaller falan filan ler hemen
toparlıyorum yine sokağa çık sokağa çık
Boşuna demiyoruz
pazarcıklı a kadar hep beraber onlarla
yaptığımız yine Beyefendinin haberinden
Daha doğrusu an olsun dan kazayı
şeylerle ve bu projeler lex uşağı
bayılır böyle sıfatları yılın kadını
falan
ben ve sevdim Yani evet hoşuma gitti
Çünkü o kuşakları biner köklerim orada
sonuçta Bu projelerden dolayı alındığı
için O sizin keyifli ve önemli de
elbette bu tür projeleri öğrencilerimiz
yaptığım için hemen derslerimizde nde bu
şekilde anılarımızı yapıp bitiriyorum
Çünkü süre mi açtığımı düşünüyorum bizim
derslerimiz böyle geçirsem Çünkü ben
hayatın kendisini o anfinin içinde
yaşatmayı seviyorum yani soğuk soğuk
sıralarda şu gözlere bakın anlaştığını
nasıl pörtlemiş halaylarla danslarla
benim evimde uyuyan yüzsüz
öğrencilerimle ben bulaşık yıkarken
uyuyor şu bunu içeride bulaşığı hocası
yıkıyor Kendisi de orada uyuyor ve son
olarak Eren bülbülü de size gösterip
Hoşçakalın diyeceğim Eren Bülbül
Karadeniz'de O bize kuşağından Yine bir
yavrumuz
şehidimiz bizim bilirsiniz Seyit olmuştu
bende
zihinsel engelli çocuklarımızın
Okulu'nda bir sanat atölyesi yaptırmak
için
yazılarımı bir kitabı çevirmişti Melen
için yazmıştım benim için çok özel bir
yeri vardır Annesini de burada paylaşmak
isterim Eren Bir de kitabımı götürdüm de
sağlığın
[Alkış]
ve hiç bir sıfatın kölesi değilim
kendime aitim diyen bu kadın Evet
bencede ilk
kuşağına inat Obi yosuna hiçbir şey
yazmaya devam edecek ve Siz bugün beni
niye dinlediniz Ben size ne anlattım
şunu anlattım aslında kendi amacınız
amaçsız aysız kendi sevdanız ona ne
tavası kışın Sevdası ya da hayali değil
kendi sevdanız Biz kendi hayalleriniz ve
Bütün bunların uğruna
deli gibi akıtacağız Emeğiniz
bu eksik olmasın Efendim hayatımızdan
teşekkür ederim